they were going to make me a a a villain
when I the you when we started and I
thought well no no no and this was when
I was studying with h with Milton when
when when all that happened and he and
he would used to say you're not going to
get this all together just start
sneaking this stuff in so so that's what
I started doing yeah cuz I realized no
this man is a father and he's trying to
make his son a better stronger man and
and so and slowly the writers started
picking up on that yes and and going
with it so I felt I felt I had a lot of
power with them I don't know if there's
a character that we talk about more than
you on the show about how much your
performance like we talk about Annette's
performance a
lot but you we always talk about on our
other podcast how much you bring there's
a there's there's anep episode well
we'll bring that up later but there's
there's just these moments where
somehow you feel for Lionel even though
you hate him he does these things to you
or to people to other characters and
then
you're oh but but the way you play it
it's so ambiguous it's so
uh subtextual or whatever it's so uh
just
it's it's layered it's not just bad bad
bad because it's easy to play that and
how many roles do you see where a lot of
times you're like oh that guy just bad I
saw this movie they remade Fright Night
2 I know I'm a big horror movie n nut uh
I have the poster Tom Holland signed it
but they made Fright Night 2 and I like
the movie but the thing I thought didn't
work was the lead character that was
originally played by Chris Sarandon who
we both love uh uh Chris sandon played
the nextdoor neighbor who was the
villain with such charm and you liked
him and but he was so bad he was he was
the bad vampire and in this one they
just he was just
bad and it just wasn't didn't have near
the impact and so that shows you that a
lot of times it's in the writing if they
would have written a scene or something
showing that he wasn't he was layered
and you charismatic something right and
a lot of writers failed to do that and
the fact that they said they started
catering towards that um that sort of
gift that you brought to
show um you I've never done a character
it seven years cuz they they killed me
in in U I killed you D yeah I know and
that was i k you and I and I talked to
the writers I said listen when you do
write me off
let licks kill
me cuz I figured that that would
really be who you became that was the
thing that pushed me over the no pun
intended push you out of window yeah
yeah you told them that I asked them I
said listen when you kill me let Lex do
it and that that and they bought it that
was one one of the most Pinnacle moments
of the show to me for my character
anyway for us us and the look you gave
me it was almost like I remember doing
the scene with you I remember and I
don't remember a lot but we're standing
there I'm about to push you and you just
looked at me
like letting
go and when you're falling out the
window sorry for spoiler alerts for Ryan
did you know that
happens yeah anyway he uh you fall and
just the look in your eye it's almost
like you're at peace with it
like it's time it was time and this is
the way I wanted to it was just I don't
know it was enigmatic and and and heavy
and but you always brought that and it
always like cuz I would get bored I
would do scenes with certain people or
you know and it was like H I'm going to
the bar I'm getting another drink I'm
sitting at my desk I'm getting knocked
out I'm you know this that the love
triangle but when I saw that I had a
scene with you I knew it was going to be
10 times better than it was on the page
because we were going to bring it we
were good together we were good together
we were really good together yeah we
were